let's talk about a mountain territory
that people are killing each other over
it's called nagorno-karabakh and the
fights between armenia and azerbaijan
a flare-up of one of the world's oldest
conflicts is raising fears of
all-out war
soldiers and civilians are being killed
life has moved underground in stepanaket
once the machine of war
started it gets incredibly dangerous
these two sides have very
long range weapons so why are they
fighting how long has it been going on
for
and why are countries like turkey
involved
[Music]
the first shots were fired in july
before all-out war broke out at the end
of september
it's been the worst fighting there in 25
years but the grievances go back
generations at the heart of the dispute
is a region called nagorno-karabakh
and here it is in a crowded neighborhood
known as the south caucasus
nagorno-karabakh lies entirely within
azerbaijan's borders
it's internationally recognized as being
part of the country
full stop here's the thing it's
controlled by ethnic armenians
backed by armenia and surrounding
nagorno-karabakh
are lands that armenia controls the un
calls it an occupation
then you've got all the big neighbors
like iran which borders both
turkey it's long been an ally of
azerbaijan and then there's russia
it supplies weapons to both armenia and
azerbaijan
we'll get into all the geopolitics later
but first
here's what nagorno-karabakh looks like
it makes up five percent of azeri
territory but almost twice that much
land around it
is controlled by armenian forces about
150
000 people live here it holds its own
elections and governs itself
but right now it's a war zone
many people are living in their
basements because of the shelling
and local officials say half the people
who live there have been forced to leave
the thing about this region is that it's
been fought over for a long time
iran had control in the mid-18th century
then the russians took over
the british and the ottomans were in
there too
but a key date in all of this is 1920.
that's when armenia and azerbaijan went
to war over nagorno-karabakh
and azerbaijan backed by russia got
control
a year later it was promised to the
armenians but stalin turned around
and made sure azerbaijan held on to it
by 1988 the soviet union was crumbling
and the armenians in nagorno-karabakh
took advantage of the power vacuum
and voted to join armenia so when the
soviet union finally fell apart in 1991
so did whatever was left of peace in the
south caucasus
what the collapse of the soviet union
did was then to militarize
this conflict both sides suddenly got
much bigger weapons
1992 was when the fighting really
intensified
right after armenians and
nagorno-karabakh declared independence
[Music]
both sides accuse each other of
atrocities tens of thousands of local
azeri's and armenians were killed
a million people had to leave their
homes
in the end the armenians pushed
azerbaijan's forces
out of nagorno-karabakh seized
territories around it
and it all finally ended in a ceasefire
in 1994
that ceasefire has been ignored by both
armenia and azerbaijan over the years
and the sense of injustice over what
happened in that war
the killings and mass displacement
hasn't gone away
this conflict has always been kind of
put on the back burner there's always
the danger of some
terrible incident causing a new
escalation in which case
things could get totally out of control
given the huge amount of
weaponry we have on both sides and now
both sides are tapping into that anger
[Music]
it's full-scale war all over again
trenches tanks
air attacks
air raid sirens wailed across this city
as a barrage of rockets and mortars
rained down
azeri forces have been attacking
nagorno-karabakh's main cities to
ponicurt
armenian men there have been signing up
to fight back
exact numbers are next to impossible to
come by but soldiers
and civilians on both sides have been
killed
armenian forces have been attacking
azerbaijan too
the border city of ganja has been among
the hardest hit
the second rocket hits the the other
street
and there are also two other wounded
people over there
[Music]
so how and why did the fighting start up
again
the answer depends entirely on who you
ask
armenia says azerbaijan attacked first
azerbaijan
says it acted in self-defense what's
clear is that it's not exactly
an even fight our colleagues at aj labs
put together these infographics to show
just how much more azerbaijan spends on
its military
how many more soldiers it has and how
much more artillery
[Music]
and the aziris have been showing it off
this is an actual music video released
by the aziri military
the armenians are rallying their people
too
but what's making this particular fight
different from all the other skirmishes
is that other countries are getting
involved in a big way
is
part of turkey's connection to
azerbaijan is cultural
the azeri's are a turkic speaking people
we call ourselves one nation two states
what happens there of course is of
direct concern to us it affects
you know our borders it affects our
region it's got the armenians in
nagorno-karabakh
looking for outside help too if there is
also a direct involvement of turkey
and i don't see that turkey is going to
pull out from the region
we have to somehow you know change
some geopolitical approaches of our
state
further strengthen our relations with
brother countries russia
united states iran and china so how
involved is turkey in the actual
fighting
well that's difficult to pin down
azerbaijan is using military drones
supplied by turkey and israel
and turkey's accused of recruiting
syrian fighters to help against the
armenians
which turkey and azerbaijan flatly deny
there is no evidence of the so-called
syrian fighters going to azerbaijan or
facilitated by us
there is evidence of lebanese armenian
individuals i guess are militia
you know going there so what's in it for
turkey and azerbaijan
beyond trying to get back what they see
as aziri land
well something to consider is that this
region is rich
in oil and gas pipelines snake across
the region
oil and gas make up 90 percent of
azerbaijan's exports
and as for turkey azerbaijan is now its
biggest supplier of natural gas
so understandably any instability here
is bad for business all around
azerbaijan accuses the armenians of
attacking a major oil pipeline which
armenia denies
one thing's for sure azerbaijan's oil
and gas has come in handy
that's given azerbaijan the revenues
to build up a new army after it had lost
a humiliating defeat back in the 1990s
the other reason turkey and azerbaijan
say they support the offensive on
nagorno-karabakh
is that they think the dispute has been
allowed to fester and now is the time
to resolve it once and for all our main
concern
is to find a diplomatic solution to this
but as i said
for this piece to be sustainable it
needs to be
based on a plan to end occupation it's
true that
over the years there have been lots of
negotiations the un's put out a bunch of
resolutions to stop the fighting
and all the big international
organizations have weighed in too
including something called the mints
group led by russia
france and the united states they came
close to getting the two sides to agree
on a peace plan
in 2007 but it fell apart the two sides
basically never really fully accepted
that plan they were always looking to
see if they could just improve their
options
but like all the other plans so far
they've failed to overcome that
deep mistrust
a ceasefire is good certainly good but
the problem must be solved
a ceasefire must solve the problem that
is our independence
one can completely understand the
armenians saying that we are the
majority population we've lived here for
centuries we're surrounded by armenian
churches
and cemeteries and we don't trust
azerbaijan to rule over us
and you can also completely understand
azerbaijan saying to take away
nagorno-karabakh is to kind of tear a
massive chunk out of the middle of our
territory and that's completely
unacceptable
both sides accuse each other of terrible
things
massacres ethnic cleansing and taking
land
so it's hard to make peace ceasefires
only pause the fighting they don't
resolve it
and history has shown that
with this story there are plenty of
accusations and denials on both sides
and as always with our show start here
we cover the basics
but we've got a lot more coverage on
aljazeera.com
and all the latest on our live blog i'll
see you next week